in the last video our alternative our
null hypothesis the drug had no effect
and our our alternative hypothesis that
the drug just has an effect we didn't
say whether the drug would lower the
response time or raise the response time
we just says the drug has an effect that
it will not the mean with when you have
the drug will not be the same thing as
the population mean and then the null
hypothesis no your mean with the drug is
going to be the same thing as the
population mean has no effect in this
situation where we're really just
testing to see if it had an effect
whether an extreme positive effect or an
extreme negative effect what if both ver
what have both been considered in effect
we did something called a two-tailed
test this is called a two-tailed test
two-tailed test because frankly a super
high response time if you had a response
time that was more than three standard
deviations that would have also made us
likely to reject the null hypothesis so
we were dealing with kind of both tails
you could have done a similar type of
hypothesis test with the same experiment
where you only have a one tailed test
and the way we could have done that is
we still could have had the null
hypothesis we still could have had the
null hypothesis be that the drug has no
effect drug has no effect or that the
mean with the drug the mean and maybe I
could say the mean with the drug is
still going to be 1.2 seconds our mean
response time now if we wanted to do a
one tailed test for some reason we
already had a you know maybe a view that
this drug would lower response times
then our alternative hypothesis and just
so you get familiar with different types
of notation some books or teachers will
write the alternative hypothesis h1
sometimes they write it as H alternative
either one either one is fine if you
want to do a one tailed test you could
say that the drug the drug lowers lowers
response time the drug lowers response
time or that the mean
with the drug is less than 1.2 seconds
now if you do a one-tailed if you do a
one-tailed test like this what we're
thinking about is what we want to look
at is all right we have our sampling
distribution and actually I can just use
the drawing that I had up here you had
your sampling distribution of the sample
mean we know what the mean of that was
it's 1.2 seconds same as the population
mean we were able to estimate its
standard deviation using our sample
standard deviation and that was
reasonable because it has a sample size
of greater than 30 so we can still kind
of deal with a normal distribution for
the sampling distribution and using that
we saw that the result the sample mean
that we got the one at one point oh five
seconds is three standard deviations
below the mean is three standard
deviations below the mean so if we look
at it let me just redraw it with our new
hypothesis test so this is the sampling
distribution
that's the sampling distribution it has
a mean right over here at one point two
seconds and the result we got was three
standard deviations below the mean three
standard deviations below the mean one
two three standard deviations below the
mean that was what our 1.05 seconds were
so when you set it up like this where
you're not just saying that the drug has
an effect what in that case and that was
the last video you'd look at both tails
but here we're saying we only cares does
the drug lower does the drug lower our
response time and just like we did
before you say okay
let's say the drug doesn't lower our
response time if the drug doesn't lower
our response time what was the
probability or what is the probability
of getting a lowering this extreme or
more extreme so here it will only be one
of the tails that we consider when we
put when we set our alternative
hypothesis like that that we think it
lowers so the problem if if if if our
null hypothesis is true the probability
of getting of getting a result
more extreme more extreme more extreme
than 1.05 seconds now we are only
considering this tail right over here
let me put it this way more extreme than
1.05 seconds or let me say lower because
in the last video we cared about more
extreme because even a really high
result would have said okay the means
definitely not one point two seconds but
in this case we care about means that
are lower so a result so now we care
about the probability of a result lower
lower than one point zero five seconds
that's the same thing as sampling from
the sample of getting a sample from the
sampling distribution that's more than
three standard deviations below the mean
and in this case we're only going to
consider the area in this one tail so
this right here would be a one tail test
where we only care about one direction
below the mean and if you look at the
one tail test this area over here we saw
last time that both of these areas
combined are 0.3% but if you're only
considering one of these areas if you're
only considering this one over here it's
going to be half of that because the
normal distribution is symmetric so it's
going to be 0.13% so this one right here
is going to be zero point or sorry 0.15
percent or if you were express it as a
decimal this is going to be point or
0.001 five so once again if you set up
your hypothesis like this you would have
said if your if your null hypothesis is
correct there would have only been a
point one five percent chance of getting
a result lower than the result we got so
we are this is practice that would be
very unlikely so we will reject we will
reject the null hypothesis and go and go
with the alternative and in this
situation your p-value your p-value is
going to be the point zero zero one five